we've been chatting with the one and
only ted danson who's back in the new
season of nbc's mr mayor all right let's
get back to it is it possible to get
ted's take um like you could in a
sentence tell us your take on blank yes
perfect okay here we go everybody
intense take
okay
your take on love
[Applause]
wow well if you're blessed
to have love to be able to love someone
and
be loved in return is really to me the
reason why we're human beings it is
the uh it's heaven on earth i love that
work
i
i don't have any wisdom i just the
reason why i'm still working at 74 is
because i love to go to work i love to
drive through studio gates i love to
turn right on james stewart avenue and
cross over gregory peck street and you
know show up at a studio and be
surrounded by crew members to you
grow to a door over the years
um
yeah i love going to work
i don't know if it defines me but it
sure
enriches my life
okay
amazing and you are up there with those
great gentlemen that you just said um
peck and stuart and danson family
family wow um mary and i both
what brings us literally the most joy
is when we sit down to a table of 12
people now
with kids grandkids wives spouses
boyfriends
12 people and we sit down and we're
surrounded by family brings us so much
joy
um it is such a bla i don't know what to
say it's such a blessing i don't have
anything wise to say except thank you no
the 12 people that painted the perfect
storytelling picture i love it the one
rule you live by
yeah you know be kind yeah be kind to
people
it's a
life can be scary and hard and tough and
all of that so be kind
yes that is perfect perfect wisdom from
you
do you think that if they came to you
with like a cheers reboot that you would
ever do it
i'm positive we would not um
first off i think our creators jimmy
burrows less and glenn charles would
would you know wouldn't want it they'd
like to rest on their laurels i'm sure
but here's what it would look like you
know we would it'd be a bunch of old
people
sitting around the bar going what what'd
you say a horse walks into a what
you know i i think i think i think there
must be an appetite for it but i'm just
gonna watch the reruns for now
and um thank you for just being kind
enough to put yourself out there on all
these incredible shows so that we can
watch you ted danson you can watch mr
mayor tuesdays at 8 30 eastern
on nbc ted i love you so much thank you
for being you i love you thank you i
love you too i'm so glad you have this
show
[Music]
you